Adriana Lima and Julian Edelman had  called it quits  he can't confirm the Victoria's Secret  model and the New England Patriots wide  receiver half split if it comes as a  surprise that these two were together in  the first place everybody it's because  they kept their relationship pretty  private a couple first sparked dating  rumors last summer but they never  officially confirmed their status et has  learned the pair broke up sometime after  the Super Bowl where Adriana was sharing  Julian on alongside his family and  friends just days after the big game the  supermodel flew solo to the Maybelline  bring on the night party and also went  stag to the Vanity Fair Oscar party last  month  [Music]